with Barnes chairs the Congressional
Oversight Panel to the troubled asset
relief program known as tar she
discusses the government's response to
the economic recession as well as
financial regulatory proposals that
include the creation of a new Consumer
Financial Protection Agency this
interview was conducted at a recent
conference of government and business
leaders hosted by bloomberg news it's
about 25 minutes of the entire tarp
program she's a Harvard Law Professor
she's been mentioned as well by House
Financial Services Committee Chairman
Barney Frank is a possible choice to run
a new Consumer Financial Protection
Agency if that ever comes out of
Congress and so we welcome her here to
the stage and leading our questioning of
a professor Warren is our own Lizzie
O'Leary of Bloomberg Television you
spent much of the last year covering
tarp and its ramifications so Lizzie
it's all yours thank you thank you very
much for coming oh sure to be here we
also neglected to mention that you've
been voted the 30th most powerful person
in Washington by GQ they like to do list
that's right I want to start with
something that I think people who
haven't been closely following the House
Financial Services debate might not know
you have the distinction of having an
amendment written to keep you from being
the head of a potential Consumer
Financial Protection Agency it did went
down and went down but I guess the
question is where did you get the
reputation for being such a troublemaker
you know I I think I've had that
reputation all my life I asked the the
kids I grew up with and my older
brothers uh but I I'm a little surprised
i have to admit by the whole thing you
know evidently just saying things and
saying pretty plain things that are
backed up by the data is enough to make
you a real troublemaker in this town so
there it is and and and yet still voted
powerful well we'll see not as powerful
i should note as the head of the
American Bankers Association so what do
you think that says about what you've
been able to accomplish with the CEO
paper well I I think it's a reminder
that
there are multiple sources of power
obviously the head of the American
Bankers Association who is more powerful
than I am has long-standing
relationships in Washington and a huge
lobbying crew and can direct a lot of
campaign contributions I'm not saying
anything that other people don't
recognize and really all we have from
the congressional oversight panel is a
very hardworking staff that does
research based reports and we call it
like we see it and let the devil take
the hindmost on the political
implications of that and that's turned
down evidently to to have some kind of
impact here in Washington but you know I
have to say you have to be careful about
this it's it's a people want to talk
about all is very powerful GQ are you
kidding you know that's not a list I
ever thought I was going to be on you
but but more importantly we really have
to remember where we are before we start
getting heady about this or or all
Hollywood or anything else oh we keep
turning out reports about how tarp money
has been used and some of the profound
changes that have taken place in our
economy as a result of this massive
intervention in the marketplace and
raising a lot of really serious issues
of and right now very little has changed
the rules are still the same as they
were a year ago despite all of our
reports despite what we've been
hammering on all the very issues that
brought us to the brink of disaster and
caused us to pass start are all still
there concentration and financial
services of toxic assets on the books of
the bank's the questions we've raised
about the stress tests of Treasury has
not answered them and has not repeated
the stress test so and we're already at
the or one percentage point aware ten
percentage point away from the stress
level of unemployment in that yeah we're
there I mean we've we've effectively
busted through that we know where we are
on those numbers and and yet we haven't
repeated any of that so it you know I I
appreciate the fact that lots of people
want to say whoa that's very powerful
that GQ wants to say that I'd rather
measure that in terms of real change
well in terms of real change why do you
think more complete legislation hasn't
come out of the relevant committees yet
well look part of it let's let's be fair
there was a presidential election right
in the middle of you know as this crisis
is is unfolding and I think that that
vastly slowed down what might have
otherwise because Chris Dodd was running
for president no no no this i'm talking
about post-september ah everyone knew
there was going to be a change of
administrations so there it was you know
in October and November which would have
ordinarily been the time that you start
collecting the data and floating the
proposals to think about how the rules
need to be changed and that didn't
happen because everyone knew there would
be someone new in all those positions
that didn't happen in October it didn't
happen in November didn't happen in
December didn't happen in January and
then in February you had a lot of new
people in and it takes a while to kind
of get everything together also you know
ultimately there's this question you
have to decide what the problem is
before you can decide what the answer is
there has to be a narrative to describe
that problem and I think there's been a
lot of dispute over the narrative and
until we sort of get locked into the
narrative we're not going to agree on on
a response what do you think it is oh I
think this is a crisis that started one
household at a time I think it started
one lousy mortgage but also other lousy
credit instruments I think it started
with a market that had shifted from a
service to consumers that by and large
kind of was low risk and low profit and
shifted over into a tricks and traps
pricing model where money was made by
purporting to sell one thing and all of
the with the industry calls revenue
enhancers were put in the back part I
think that was the start of it I think
that fed enormous risk into
system I think there's those risks
rather than being dispersed were
actually aggregated and they were auto
correlated risks so they magnified in
terms of their impact I think that that
the fancy financial instruments help
that along very nicely and we ended up
at the other end with a with a great
crisis and when the moment came would
the government crossed the threshold and
support these huge financial
institutions that had made profound
mistakes would it do that and leave
equity in place leave management in
place leave all of the creditors with no
hair cut at all I mean we're talking in
historic question secretary of the
Treasury Paulson said yes we will we'll
put that money in and he made a change
in this economy that frankly I think a
lot of people are just starting to see
some of the implications of that with
the too-big-to-fail debate for example
well I want to ask you about the
too-big-to-fail debate because Jamie
Dimon was making made the case in in the
post today that banks should be allowed
to be big very big that their creates
that creates economies of scale for
consumers for businesses we certainly do
not see in any of the plans that have
been generated in Congress real
disassembly of mega banks should that be
in these bills so I want to make two
points about too big to fail I think we
really have a toolbox that has two kinds
of tools in it the first set of tools
are what I think of as the regulation
tools and for me this tool box has 25
screwdrivers in it where you can kind of
dial up and dial back and it's
everything from we want let banks get
above a certain size will make it more
expensive for them to attract capital
through these ten regulatory structures
will make them pay into an insurance
fund will put oversight over them but
they're all regulatory tools that sort
of like little screwdrivers you just
keep dialing up and back on where you
think that works that will someday fail
because it will be
human beings because smart people who
run big corporations are always looking
for the way around the edges to get
around these and that always asks us
then about the second tool in the
toolbox the second tool in the toolbox
is a hammer and what the hammer does is
it says in effect here's what happens if
you make monumentally bad decisions and
bring your company to a position that it
can't pay its outstanding debts and you
are too big to fail so what are we going
to do with those companies and for me
this is all about resolution authority
you have to remember my background I
actually come out of background of
chapter 11 so can we credibly say that
if you get too deeply interwoven you
somehow threaten the rest of the economy
we nonetheless have a way to unwind you
and frankly it's a way so that the
politicians don't get involved in it at
the moment so that someone yelling at
the house is on fire the house is on
fire that's not the way that we devised
this but it's much more about what
happens to equity what happens to debt
what happens to management if you ever
have to call in the American taxpayer
again so so I'm I I want to look at this
in a kind of unified level because I
think that's how it really works do you
think well there's been a big debate
about who should fund that uh and we've
seen this idea that there might be some
sort of a float from the taxpayers and
then a fee assessed on big banks or that
they should have to pay up front uh
something I rarely heard Barney Frank
essentially admitted they made a mistake
in their initial go at this which would
take the money out the back end should
there be a kitty up front like an FDIC
fund like I said I just see that as one
of the 25 screwdrivers this is one of
the ways that you both increase the cost
of being big and set aside some reserve
if we got some part of the but we got
some part of this wrong I think that
that if we are going to treat certain
institutions as too big to fail
then the answer is if they have a
guarantee it's an insurance fund from
the federal government if they have a
caring T from the federal government but
they turn will have to pay for it the
idea that they will have guarantee and
not pay for it is the one that frankly
just completely unravels the entire
capitalist system well let's talk about
a guarantee that you have talked about
investigated uh and I don't think most
Americans fully understand they see the
700 billion dollar number as the
headline number of the tarp program
let's talk about the debt guarantees
yeah your your staff put out a report
your last report said that they have
lowered the bar and costs for big banks
by thirty nine percent and that the
actual number the taxpayers are floating
here is more like what four four point
three trillion debt at its peak and it's
we're winding back out of that but at
its peak how dangerous was that it was
dangerous but let's always remember the
counter-argument is it was no more
dangerous than watching the entire
economy go down which is what people
thought was the alternative so it's
always whatever what do you think was
the alternative it was very dangerous
but the real impact is that it changes
pricing in this fundamental way it
changes the cost of capital those who
have you know consider to financial
institutions one has this guarantee
whether it's implicit or explicit the
other one doesn't they pay very
different amounts for capital over any
period of time it's not just that one is
operating cheaper it's draining away
capital from from other institutions
that don't have the guarantee so that's
profound and obviously the the other
part is the what we call the moral
hazard part of it it changes the
business model if i can get a complete
guarantee from you have I got a business
model for you because the business model
becomes give me your money I will go to
Las Vegas and bet it all on red 22 if it
comes in we're rich and if it doesn't
come in my friend the tax
we'll give you your money back we'll
make sure that you're guaranteed because
this was a debt obligation they just
can't be right so the big question with
the guarantees is we know how to unwind
the explicit guarantees we've got that
one but what do we do about the implicit
guarantees look look right now at money
market funds oh we rushed in on sep
tember 18th a year ago when the money
market funds were about to break the bog
and we took a deep breath and suddenly
realized if it breaks the buck and
people fully money market funds we have
enough liquidity in our systems so I
understand the reason but we jump in on
money market funds they paid a
substantial fee and look somebody could
look at this and say and you made a
profit because we guaranteed those funds
we didn't have to pay out on them and we
got fees from the companies that that
had the money markets but that guarantee
expired on sep tember 18th of this year
very quietly is there anyone left in
America who doesn't believe that if
money market funds threatened to break
the BOK again that the federal
government won't come rushing back in so
there's in my view an implicit guarantee
for which those money market funds pay
nothing and we have as taxpayers no
protection but we're all operating now
with a new implicit guarantee and it
distorts the market and change this
risk-taking behavior and that can't be
right I I want to ask you about because
you've written about to income families
you have written about the role of women
moving into the economic realm it's hard
to miss that two of the most vocal
people in the financial crisis in
Washington are women you and sheila bair
reminded me Ben is are you saying women
are mouthy yeah I just want to make sure
I'm following this do you think you're
viewed as
as Malby women I I think we are I mean I
I think so but I I you know she was kind
of a plain-spoken woman from Kansas i'm
sort of a plain-spoken woman from
Oklahoma I'm not sure whether it's our
oak eNOS or a womanliness that causes it
to work out this way but yeah I think we
both just say what we think about this
we're going to take questions from the
audience in just a sec I want to ask you
do you want to be the head of the cfpa I
want there to be a CFP a and that's the
part I care passionately about the last
thing I want is for this to be about
personalities uh I really do right now
we have an agency that we desperately
need both to stabilize American families
and frankly for the stability of the
American economy I think it has both
implications we have got to turn that
market for consumer credit around and
make it work better I'm a huge believer
in markets but we need better support
for this market and and to take the
tricks and traps pricing model out I
just want to see this agency go through
do you think it's going to I'm a lot
more hopeful than I was before you know
when I first started with this two years
ago everyone told me you know it forget
it now the bank's always win this is
back to the question you started with
about Ed angling they reminded me that
the banks have all the money the banks
have all the lobbyists the banks have
all the influence on Capitol Hill and
they always always always win and at
least right in this moment we just may
have a window where that's not true why
haven't there been restrictions on
lobbying for banks taking tarp funds we
just had a story out that city which
owes us 45 billion dollars has 46
lobbyists the most they dispute the
number i should say that that is a
everyone under their employ and they say
no tarp funds are used for lobbying
everyone makes that argument but excuse
me they these are the same people who
simply we said how did you
is the money we can't tell you because
money is fungible but evidently when
we're talking about lobbying money is no
longer fun jable they can tell for sure
that they never used tart money in order
to lobby all I can say about this one is
this is something that I think that a
congressional oversight panel should
have looked into and my bipartisan panel
has elected not to okay I'm going to go
ahead and take some questions I think we
have one over here
we're gonna get you a mic with something
a little more oomph do it look a little
better Brian I'm sorry thank you let me
try it again the cfpa is going to be a
centralization of the Consumer
Protection Authority now is dispersed
amongst number of agencies and one of
the provisions in the bill would
actually transfer the people from those
agencies over i believe the it seems
that if the argument is that government
failed to protect consumers why is the
response more government with the same
people and the second if I may aspect of
this is that the concept of taking
consumer protection laws warranties and
transferring them over to investment
products are you concerned at all about
creating unrealistic expectations in the
minds of the consumers that somehow
they're going to be protected at a level
that probably they won't be well I I
think the first point is what do you
really think went wrong in this
marketplace from the government's point
of view what did the government do wrong
and in my view it is a structural
problem the problem however is not the
civil servants who you know didn't know
how to what they were you know how an
interest rate works or what a trick
looks like back on page 16 the problem
was at the top and the top is that by
having multiple agencies they competed
for the business of these financial
institutions so that for example the OCC
needed the financial institutions to
come and be regulated by the OCC and it
was the financial institutions choice
and the financial institution could say
you know I don't like the way the SEC is
regulating me I'll simply shift my
charter and become a thrift and still
have federal protection or I will decide
to go to the states instead of being
chartered at the federal level that
would have and and when it happened it
did have profound economic consequences
for the agency because the agencies get
as much as eighty five percent of their
budget from those they regulate so what
this really net was
regulatory competition became a
competition to regulate least who could
offer the least of protection for
consumers and the the most openings for
those financial institutions to do
whatever they basically wanted to do
that's the part that changes when you
concentrate I don't think it's about
civil servants I think this is about the
overall structure and quite frankly
that's why you have to have an
independent agency you know most of the
powers that we're talking about with
this agency already exist the Fed has
had them for more than a decade and not
use them at all so the notion is to
change away from that the only point on
the last one sure you know will
expectations be higher than you can
ultimately deliver I don't know I mean I
hope not ah but what I really believe in
here are fairly simple instruments that
people can read and understand and when
they can do that they can make decisions
that are in their own best economic
interests they can decide if they want
to take on those costs they can decide
if they want to take on those risks with
a tricks and traps pricing model that
opportunity is denied them so that's the
part I feel quite sure that this agency
can deliver on I think some movement
over here doin out of runner is that
just me being crazy person crazy person
I want to ask you then if on this CFPA
issue the argument is that can you
separate out safety and soundness
stability from the product there's a lot
a lot of folks who say no no you need
the same regulator there do you think
that confuses here a lot of folks who
say we like the status quo just fine and
please leave it the way it is and those
folks are the banks and the current
regulators so do I think those two
things can be separated of course they
can be separated they separate them in
Canada and they've done just fine in
fact what happened in Canada is they
were able to avert much of this crisis
because they had stronger consumer
financial protection I don't think
ultimately it helps financial
institutions to be able to
issue products that destabilize not only
the families but the economy and the
institution's themselves let's go out
here hi Elizabeth Chris Fralick from
first round capital I've heard you speak
before about the the problem of our
national debt and our deficit and I just
like to hear your thoughts if you looked
out ten years what do you think is the
best case of what we might be there or
and what happens in the worst case well
it's a it's a tough one right now you
know this is this is trying to look out
of a storm and predict what it's going
to look like when things are calm again
without knowing for sure what changes in
the storm if that makes any sense what
kind of what interests me right now is
what the new rules are going to look
like because I think the new rules in
financial services and I mean that all
the way from the Consumer Agency to
resolution authority will profoundly
affect the rest of those economic
questions if we can strengthen the
middle class again if we can if we can
can help them manage risk better and
make it more transparent if they can
begin to see costs and dial away from
high risk strategies and if we can do
other things that strengthen the middle
class I think ultimately the long-term
good economic impact of that will be
something we can measure if we can't do
that if we back off and leave
middle-class America as the turkey of
the Thanksgiving dinner for everyone
else to feast off then I think it's
going to show up in in every aspect of
our economy in the future including
deficits that they're beyond our
imagination just going back to the
consumer protection agency it sounds to
me and I forget who said the quote
originally a deja vu all over again in
the early part of the decade we had
reggae c4 Wall Street research we had a
mutual fund scandal which gave us a
bunch of disclosures and other
regulations that have come down the pike
and consumer still
lost money in the stock market last year
and what you're describing in the
consumer protection financially seems a
lot like we've already done in a lot of
places five or six years ago reg FD and
it didn't solve the problem I'm just I
don't know the solution here but it
doesn't seem to me when I'm hearing last
couple days at the regulatory forefront
there's nothing innovative it hasn't
been tried in the last five years and
people were told are protected and they
weren't i profoundly disagree and I
disagree at two different levels so the
first one is we have used a completely
different approach to consumer
regulation in the past what we have
always said is let me identify a
specific problem and then let me fry up
a little solution to that problem and
then let me put it on a stack of a
zillion other solutions that we have and
that's what consumer protection looks
like it looks like this big stack of
cold pancakes now they will never
integrated they were never put together
and what happened is we just kept making
everything longer more complicated more
inaccessible over time what the Consumer
Financial Protection Agency is about is
about making these products simple and
transparent for people to see and use
and that is profoundly different the
thing that interests me most about this
agency is it comes with a pair of
scissors it doesn't just come with
rulemaking ability it comes with the
ability to say all of those disclosures
for example that simply provide
camouflage for places to hide other
tricks and traps so that no one will see
them it consider all of that away and
get this this credit card this mortgage
this overdraft arrangement down to
something that's page two pages long I
want to point out the American
Enterprise Institute actually has
samples of some of these get it down to
something people can read people can
understand and people can make better
decisions for that's a sea change that
doesn't look like anything we've tried
in the past well we unfortunately have
to wrap up because we're out of time but
thank you so much please it was quick
the US House Gamble's back in today at
two p.m. Eastern following a week-long
district work period among the six bills
to be considered increase